♪♪
>>> AND WELCOME TO LEXUS
INTERMISSION REPORT.
A ZERO-ZERO GAME AFTER ONE
PERIOD IN CHICAGO.
EARLIER THIS EVENING THE
BLACKHAWKS HELD A TOWN HALL
MEETING TO DISCUSS THE FUTURE OF
THE ORGANIZATION AND THE SEARCH
FOR A NEW PERMANENT GM.
THE PANEL CONSISTS OF ROCKY
WERTS, CEO DANNY WERTZ AND JAMIE
FAULKNER.
EDDIE OLCZYK MODERATED.
FANS WERE PRESENT.
SO WERE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA.
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW EXACTLY THE
TEAM IS MOVING FORWARD FOLLOWING
THE KYLE BEACH LAWSUIT WERE
ASKED.
>> I THINK MUCH OF WHAT HAPPENED
TO KYLE BEACH STEMMED FROM A
POWER IMBALANCE BETWEEN A COACH
AND A PLAYER AND THE
POWERLESSNESS OF A PLAYER IN
THAT SITUATION.
WHAT ARE THE BLACKHAWKS DOING?
WHAT HAVE THE BLACKHAWKS DONE?
WHAT WILL THE BLACKHAWKS DO TO
EMPOWER A PLAYER IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN?
>> I WILL ANSWER THE QUESTION.
I THINK THE REPORT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF.
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE INVOLVED
ARE NO LONGER HERE.
WE ARE NOW LOOKING BACK AT 2010.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
2010.
I KNOW.
I AM NOT EITHER.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD.
THAT IS MY ANSWER.
WHAT'S YOUR NEXT QUESTION?
>> I CAN PICK UP, TOO, WHAT WE
ARE DOING TODAY.
>> NO.
THAT'S NONE OF YOUR BUSINESS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY OF YOUR
BUSINESS.
YOU DON'T WORK FOR THE COMPANY.
IF SOMEONE IN THE COMPANY ASKS
THAT QUESTION, WE'LL ANSWER IT.
AND I THINK YOU SHOULD GET ON TO
THE NEXT SUBJECT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
KYLE BEACH.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED.
WE'RE MOVING ON.
WHAT MORE DO I HAVE TO SAY?
YOU WANT TO KEEP SOMETHING THE
SAME QUESTION AND HEAR THE SAME
ANSWER?
OKAY.
ASK THE NEXT QUESTION.
>> THAT WAS A QUESTION ASKED BY
MARK LAZARUS OF THE ATHLETIC, A
SIMILAR QUESTION POSED LATER AND
ROCKY WIRTZ DOUBLED DOWN.
IT'S STUNNING.
IT'S BEYOND DISAPPOINTING TO SIT
THERE AND SAY IN A MATTER THIS
SERIOUS, YOU ARE DONE WITH IT,
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT IT,
THAT'S IT, WE ARE MOVING ON AND
WE DON'T HAVE TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR WHAT
THEIR PLAN IS.
YOU SAW DANNY TRY TO JUMP IN.
I WISH HE WOULD HAVE JUMPED IN
AND PROTECTED HIS DAD AND SAID,
HEY, DAD, I GOT THIS.
I AM THE NEW CEO.
I AM THE GUY LEADING THIS
OPERATION GOING FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR EXACTLY
WHAT HIM AND JAMIE AND FAULKNER,
THE PRESIDENT OF BUSINESS
OPERATIONS HAS TO SAY.
HE CAME IN, HE HAD A BONE TO
PICK WITH THAT WRITER GOING IN.
NO MATTER WHAT HE SAID, THE
WRITER COULD HAVE SAID, YOU HAD
A GREAT JACKET ON.
HE WOULD HAVE THAT SAME
REACTION.
>> YOU MAKE MISTAKES.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU TALK ABOUT THEM AND DO
THINGS ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN'T HIDE IT.
AND I AM A COACH.
I USED TO BE A COACH.
I WANT TO KNOW MAYBE THERE IS
WAYS OF WHAT WOULD I DO
DIFFERENT OR AS AN ASSISTANT
COACH, IF THESE THINGS HAPPEN.
THE PROTOCOLS TO DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF ROCKY, I THINK
HE JUST -- HE WAS UPSET ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE AND JUST -- I
WOULD LOVE TO -- DANNY TO SAY
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING.
DISAPPOINTED HOW THAT WENT DOWN.
>> I WOULD THINK AS A PLAYER,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU ARE IMPARTIAL,
YOU ARE NOT A BLACKHAWKS PLAYER
BUT WATCHING THIS, I MEAN, YOU
WANT A TEAM WILLING TO SHARE
THAT INFORMATION AND TALK ABOUT
THIS.
>> LISTEN, FROM EVERY POINT OF
VIEW, THIS IS JUST A HORRIBLE
SCENARIO, HORRIBLE SITUATION
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT YOUNG MAN.
BUT I AM SITTING HERE THINKING,
AS A PARENT, YOU ARE SITTING
THERE GOING, MY SON IS 18 YEARS
OLD.
HE IS GOING TO MAYBE BE DRAFTED
BY THAT TEAM.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE -- AND I'M
SURE THEY DO HAVE THINGS IN
PLACE THAT CAN PROTECT THOSE
KIDS MOVING FORWARD.
BUT, OBVIOUSLY, AS YOU SAID,
ACE, THERE WAS SOME ILLNESS
BETWEEN THE TWO BEFORE THAT
MEETING EVEN STARTED.
>> BUT, YEAH, THE BOTTOM LINE
IS, FIRST OFF, IT'S A TOWN HALL
SETTING.
THE IDEA IS TO SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WITH FANS AND PEOPLE
IN THE ORGANIZATION, PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THE ORGANIZATION.
IF YOU HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE LI